joining me now to talk about is
cryptocurrency expert Leia Halpern Leia
thanks a lot for your time so uh you and
I have discussed this topic before but
now it appears they're doubling down
they really want this isn't this the
ultimate surveillance and control
mechanism a government-controlled
digital currency
it absolutely is and I think it's also
quite positive that we're starting to
see more Senators more Republicans
actually speaking out against this
because I also saw
um Senator Ted Cruz you know he's also
proposing the same band as Rhonda Santos
and so we have to understand what it is
it's going to be a programmable digital
currency and so since it's going to be
issued by the central bank they have the
ability to program the money however
they see fit so down to say you know you
want to host a barbecue and you buy some
sausages some meat some steaks or
whatever it is you could then have your
money declined the following week when
you go to fill up your car because you
may have reached let's say your carbon
allowance because right now we're living
through this so-called climate crisis
and they're desperately trying to
implement a carbon allowance well how do
you do this you just program the money
and so it allows these um these
politicians to to enforce more
compliance and actually enforce their
political and work agendas now you use
the word surveillance and that's
actually exactly correct because any
type of privacy that we think we may
have left will be utterly diminished
because with the Central Bank digital
honestly it's a ledger that the
government will have the absolute access
to so they will be able to see every
single transaction you have ever made
and this is why I'm a huge advocate for
Bitcoin because Bitcoin is entirely
decentralized and entirely Anonymous
however I do want to make clear that
it's not necessarily private and that is
an issue that many people have with many
different cryptocurrencies because Dan
if I send you one Bitcoin or one eth
you'll actually be able to see how much
money I have in my wallet so I'm also
very interested in looking at privacy
coins because this is going to be a
direct solution to the surveillance
that's coming and there are many people
building this we have Tommy net for
example who are building a decentralized
internet and are actually building
privacy coins so in order to combat this
surveillance this this this so the
socialism that's coming we're going to
see um we're going to need something
like Bitcoin and privacy coins
yeah lay I agree with you the
surveillance portion is the worst part
they told us our tax records would be
private too that turned out to be a joke
we've seen that thanks a lot for your
time really appreciate it